hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my American Gods
episode one video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet this
has been one of the shows I've been
looking forward to all year Bryan Fuller
did an amazing job all the actors all
the performers the visual style was
crazy I love the way they opened it with
that Viking sequence explaining pretty
much everything you need to know about
the series about how the gods came to
America so if you're new to the channel
I am doing an American Gods giveaway for
all the episode videos that I'm doing
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
it's just like my Game of Thrones
giveaways it's basically for a $20
Amazon gift card so just like the other
videos I'll do top 10 WTF and Easter
eggs as I go along I'll explain what
some of the symbolism means there's some
very special objects like the coins that
he got from Matt Sweeney as well as the
gallows the Buffalo mr. Wednesday so
I'll try to explain what everything is
what they represent and what's going on
just based on this episode because
there's still a lot of stuff they
haven't revealed yet so number 10 coming
to America mr Ibis explains how people
brought their gods with them to America
starting with the Vikings in the god
odin and it explains in this very
wonderful artful way how it is that gods
are invoked how sacrifice brings them in
very literally what it is that Odin
wants to grant his boon he wants blood
to be shed he's a battle god he wants
people to make war that gives him his
power so the Vikings kill a couple of
each other Odin is appeased and brought
to America like he's physically invoked
and manifests in America even though you
don't physically see what he looks like
mostly because they don't want to tip
the hat too soon most of you if you know
the etymology of the word Wednesday
where that comes from from Loudoun what
does that sound like
sounds like Odin so they pretty much
reveal everything you need to know about
the series where it's headed what they
can do what their powers are in a much
more open way than the book ever did so
the book kept a lot of its secrets to
the very end but the really beautiful
thing that the TV series is doing is
showing you all of its cards up front
being very honest about who these
characters are I can see through you
shadow with my one eye so most of you
probably figure that out in this episode
but mr. Abbott's the one who's keeping a
record of all this who's narrating this
is also the god
sauce whose the ancient Egyptian god of
writing wisdom and magic so it's
basically his job to narrate what's
going to be happening this season so you
touch base with him every once in a
while in most of the big main characters
that shadow runs into are gods in some
form or another but number nine we meet
shadow and Loki live Smith so what does
that name sound like Loki which is a
really funny twist but he says I smell
snow so Loki's life Smith starts
spinning all these tales she just has
word vomit coming out of him and it
sounds a little bit like nonsense but
what he's trying to do is get shadow to
open his mind shadow says I only believe
things that I can see so a big part of
Shadows arc through the course of the
series and the reason he has the visions
of the bison the world tree which I'll
explain in a second is because he's
slowly opening his mind to the
supernatural world gods do exist but he
hasn't quite learned that yet what his
role is and why it is that it always
gets really overcast and snows when he
gets really anxious so like you notice
as he goes to bed and he's really
pensive it starts snowing outside his
window but the dream he has I totally
love the cinematography and the way they
transition from his conscious mind to
his sleeping mind as he sees Laura then
you transition to the bone orchard which
is the metaphor for all the death that's
coming so all this is foreshadowing for
things that are going to come to pass so
it's very literally dead bodies just all
around the world treated Klaus at him so
what he's seeing here is the World Tree
from Norse mythology looking like it's
trying to take him and hang him like you
see the noose hanging down here he saw
that earlier during the day that later
in the episode he literally gets hung
from a tree so all these are things that
are going to come to pass so you notice
it is he's dreaming he's getting visions
of the future some supernatural force at
play that's trying to explain to him
what's going on but he hasn't quite
broadened his mind yet so he doesn't
really know what to make of it it's all
still very confusing he and he hasn't
referenced it at all during the day so
the title of the episode was the bone
orchard
it's just foreshadowing what's to come
there's this big war that's been teased
between the gods the old gods and the
new gods that's what all the imagery
with the battle at the beginning of the
episode was about they pretty much told
you what the entire plot of the series
was so shadow is getting a vision of the
graveyard of everyone's body that's why
they call it the bone orchard because
bone orchard is another term for a
graveyard so he's witnessing all these
supernatural graves here so war of the
gods a bunch of people are going to die
but you have to remember that this is a
supernatural war so it's not people
fighting people it's God's fighting gods
but I love number eight do not piss off
those in airports so this is
another lesson from Loki trying to get
him to see things in very simple terms
trying to get into broad his mind so he
tells them this big parable about how a
prisoner got out of prison went to the
airport pissed off one of the women at
the airport and ended up right back in
prison
so one it's an example of someone trying
to exert influence on shado and get him
to go in a certain direction this shadow
might not necessarily go in on its own
like he probably would have thrown down
and gotten thrown back in prison because
he has a temper you started to see that
as he starts fighting Matt Sweeney
totally loved in McShane's intro playing
the fool trying to get the first class
upgrade just showing you what an amazing
con man mr. Wednesday is Indian exchange
just does it so well he just acts
circles around everybody else but all
the actors on the show work great but I
love the way that he's talking to shado
being so upfront he covers all the basic
concepts about how faith keeps the plane
up faith keeps the gods up so everything
that mr. Wednesday says is a metaphor
for what's going on in the series and
what's coming up so if it sounds like
there's some hidden meaning in the
things that he's saying like I have one
eye or the cashews the metaphor the
cashews was great too
so he says they grow in another country
just like gods come from a different
country gods come from all over the
world all different religions but they
thrive in America just like cashews so
that's sort of a hat tip for later in
the episode when you see the bill quiz
scene where she's adapted to new forms
of worship using the dating service to
get the faith in the prayers that she
needs to get her power probably the most
important thing that mr. Wednesday says
though and he's very final about it is
when he says I usually get my way given
enough time it's just a matter of faith
so he also sort of subverts shadows coin
trick later which I'll talk about is
also on my list because the coin trick
was a big part of the episode where
shadow reveals to him that he's
also something of a conman he's amazing
with coin tricks and he can always get
it to come up tails except when he's
flipping against mr. Wednesday so they
don't really explain it till Matt
Sweeney comes up but I'll say number
seven what's today Wednesday let's go
with that
so that's just a way of showing you that
gods have many different names the fact
that he's finding shadow on a Wednesday
is no coincidence
so that'll play in later in the series
so I don't reveal too much up front but
if you want you can read the book ahead
but a lot of these circumstances seem
engineered that's because they are it is
no coincidence that Wednesday
Wodan Oden found shadow on a Wednesday
so it must be my lucky day but you come
to find out eventually that pretty much
every day is mr. Wednesday's lucky day
but this is so cool when shadow finally
goes to sleep on the plane you meet the
Buffalo for the first time standing next
to the World Tree so he keeps going back
to this place but the Buffalo speaks to
him and says believe with mr.
Wednesday's voice so it might be
confusing but they just want you to
think that there's something
supernatural about mr. Wednesday because
he hears his voice speaking from the
Buffalo but in the book the Buffalo
itself is a representative of the land
so it's like the land has an avatar
just like other gods have avatars
walking around like Sweeney says that
he's a leprechaun so when you're
speaking to the Buffalo you are very
literally speaking to the earth itself
but in the book the Buffalo is a
completely different character that
isn't really connected to mr. Wednesday
is the earth trying to speak to shadow
trying to get him to open his mind
number 6 torture in the Bilquis scene
so you see shadow going down the road
screaming these clouds sort of come out
over him almost like he's calling the
weather with his rage and you
transitioned to the dating service that
Bilquis has where she meets with the man
takes into bed and then basically just
consumes him through his prayers and
makes herself younger so that's how she
takes her powers in but it was so well
done and if you're wondering how they
pulled off that crazy trick there was a
trapdoor beneath the bed so the actor
would like slip underneath as they were
filming that it is a little crazy
camerawork just to make him seem like he
was getting smaller and smaller but if
you're wondering what her powers are
she's the queen of sheba into gin and it
a way of showing you how she's adapted
to new forms of worship but she draws on
their faith in the same way that's why
he has to pray to her for her to get
that power but such a great transition
to the crocodile's mouth so number five
and for the coin toss and then shadow
sealing the deal so he bets heads or
tails and I explained a little bit about
how shadow can win any coin toss he's a
master with coin tricks except when he's
flipping against mr. Wednesday because
as you learned through Matt Sweeney's
character it is much easier to pull them
out of thin air because shadows like
what's the trick I don't understand he
does it by sleight of hand just like a
normal magician would but Matt Sweeney
who's a leprechaun has supernatural
power he just pulls coins out of thin
air so that's why he jokes about it
being so difficult to hide all those
coins up your sleeves that sounds like
too much trouble but that sort of helps
you understand why it is that he can't
win the coin toss against mr. Wednesday
because mr. Wednesday is using his power
in the way they seal the deal is very
important to the second one seals the
deal the third one's the charm so a
seemingly meaningless ritual like
sharing a drink with your friend in a
very special way very specific way
actually invokes a very special ancient
power it's just a way of showing you
that there is power in ritual but did
the ritual itself is very important the
intent behind it is also important but
you have to do it in a certain way he
had to take all three shots of that meat
in order to seal the bargain seal the
bond between them which is also part of
what helps save him when the technical
boy was getting ready to murder him so
I'll explain that at the end of this but
if he didn't spot it there was an easter
egg here when he's looking at the
obituary
Dane Cook plays Robbie the person that
died in the car crash with his wife
Laura but I just love the way that a
couple of the characters like mr.
Wednesday are a little more roundabout
in the way they tried to reveal
information to shadow but Sweeney comes
right out super drunk I'm a leprechaun
it's magic he is 100% up front about
everything
do you know Wednesday do you know who he
really is do you know what he really is
in shadows like I don't know what you're
talking about then they get into the
fight over the special gold coin a very
special gold coin I really want to
explain what the coin is but they
haven't revealed what is
going to do now that it sunk into
Laura's grave but you've actually seen
her in the trailer so I'll say spoiler
warning when I get ready to explain that
but number three the funeral so you go
and Robbie's wife gets all crazy
explains how they die so I know it seems
like they're trying to throw Laura under
the bus make her seem like this
unfaithful wife but you have to remember
that a lot of these circumstances seemed
like they were engineered by outside
forces like all of this is intended to
drive shadow towards a destiny that he
isn't aware of yet that he's slowly
awakening to so actually just to jump
back mr. Wednesday when he's trying to
hustle for that first-class seat he says
he's trying to get to his nephew's
christening that was kind of like the
meed that he shared with shadow it's
part of the ritual so it's almost like
shadow is getting his christening so
they really are revealing a lot of stuff
up front I know she gets super crazy
it's so funny like her flipping out I'm
trying to get a little bit of my dignity
back don't be so crazy as he tosses the
coin onto the grave and it sinks beneath
the ground
so without completely giving the coin
away I will say that the coin itself is
very important number two shadow meets
the technical boy and there are a couple
big changes from the book here the
technical boy is the god of the internet
so what they do on the TV show because
modern-day Internet is much more about
virtual reality emerging technology so
that's why he speaks the shadows through
that virtual reality environment using
the facehugger device that was so cool
when the book was originally written in
the early 2000s the internet was still
dial-up so the limo that they met in was
an actual real-life limo and it was more
of like this pudgy little boy like
somebody who lives in his mother's
basement but the technical boy the TV
show is made to reflect the modern
Internet of today which is vastly
different from what it was like in the
early 2000s so he questions them about
mr. Wednesday's shadow still hasn't
quite figured out what's going on all he
knows is that he's there to protect mr.
Wednesday he doesn't know anything about
him other than he's not what he seems so
they take him out they hang him up and
then all the sudden the technical boys
men just burst into Gore all around him
with this unseen force attacking them
saving shadow's life they're very
cryptic about it but it's basically mr.
Wednesday saving shadow through his
power because of the
today's filled with the me that's one of
the important benefits and actually I
almost forgot to mention when Wednesday
is telling shadow what the terms of
their deal are that is very important
for shadowing for the future in the
unlikely event of my debt you must stand
vigil over my body very important for
later in this series so remember
everything that mr. Wednesday says if it
seems like it's an offhanded turn of
phrase it's not there is deeper meaning
in everything that comes out of mr.
Wednesday's mouth so the explosion of
gore was actually my number one but let
me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode and what you know what
are your big questions about the gods
they pretty much explain everything you
need to know about the series in the
first episode where they're headed what
the conflict is what the terms are what
they're fighting over they're fighting
over faith how we're all building
towards this big bone orchard towards
the end of the series so they're not
going to cover every single thing in the
book the first season but depending on
you guys interest level and how this
video does I'll do videos week to week
or at least the video for every couple
episodes but they're only eight episodes
so we'll see how it goes while you wait
for my next video you can click here for
a brand new game of Thrones and you can
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you